hey youtubers is Charlie so tonight is
the first night of comic-con they're
screening the Supergirl pilot so I
thought it was time to do my
non-spoilery review most of you probably
won't be able to see it till the fall so
I'll do another review with Easter eggs
and spoilers whenever that airs for
those that are wondering they actually
moved up the premiere date so officially
the series is gonna start at the end of
October it's a Monday night show at 8:00
p.m. so it's on like at the same time as
flash and arrow art during the night so
it'll be like Mondays Supergirl
Tuesday's the flash and then Wednesday's
arrow you can also consider the other DC
shows kind of part of that universe like
you know Gotham also airs on Fox
Gotham's in there too that that's still
a Monday night show but I try to treat
the Berlanti shows as like their own
separate arrowverse so just rewind in
time just a little bit if you guys
remember last year this exact same thing
happened with the flash they aired it a
little bit early you know every bunch of
people got a chance to see it really
early in the year that can be bad
sometimes especially when there's a lot
of marketing behind something just
because you don't have any context for
what you're seeing like you don't
understand what their intent is you just
have to figure it out yourself so a lot
of times you can misinterpret certain
things which I feel like is happening
with this Supergirl pilot the fact that
it's made by the same people that make
the flash should give you an idea for
their intent that they're really trying
to go with the same type of tone for
that show even arrow is swinging just a
little bit lighter I think they just had
so much success with the flash with the
way they wrote it the way they conceived
that that they wanted to replicate that
as much as possible with another
character some of you might point out
the Supergirl is one of the angriest
characters in the DC Universe but that's
not really the show that they're making
this is a show about a girl finding her
place in the world Superman does exist I
mean don't plan on seeing him a whole
lot but it's like you know what do you
do when the world already has a god-like
figure it's like it doesn't need you so
what are you gonna do I'm a big fan of
the way the flash uses humor so I'm
hoping that we get to see a lot of that
on Supergirl too because you have like a
super-powered being so how could you not
use those powers for comedy
it's harder to do that when she's pissed
off all the time so you get an idea of
like how it's it's much harder to build
a series around an angry Supergirl than
it is around like like it just a normal
Supergirl typically what happens with
pilots though is that like everyone's
still trying to figure the characters
like it took him all year on the flash
even as different writers approached
different characters you know they all
try to find their voices along with the
actors themselves like Grant Gustin said
that every single day on set he learned
something new so you kind of look at the
first season of any show as a crash
course and whatever group of characters
they're dealing with and for those that
are asking yes they will be able to do
other like Superman universe characters
people from those comics but as you seen
from the trailers the way they're
surfacing a lot of those is through the
Phantom Zone like that that's where a
lot of like the threats are gonna come
from when everyone does have a chance to
watch it I'll do a spoiler breakdown
where I explain who these people are
working for who the villains are and
based on the way they treated the flash
characters how everything might go down
this season even though it's part of the
Berlanti verse it's technically like
kind of like often a bubble on the
outside of the arrow first like it's
like a pocket universe for now the
problem is is that even though the
writers the producers everyone that
works on the show wants to cross over
with air in the flash the network
executives at CBS have to okay it and
they said season 1 probably not gonna do
any crossovers but if you remember the
way arrow dealt with superpowers a
couple years ago rewind to arrow season
1 superpowers don't exist that was the
party line from the producers they're
like superpowers don't exist in this
universe cut to season 2 we see Barry
Allen boom superpowers everywhere season
3 we start to see some magic via the
Lazarus Pit season 4 we get the time
travel so even though they say season 1
Supergirl no crossovers with air on the
flash just wait til season 2 and
typically what happens in a season
especially a season with like 20-plus
episodes is they'll do like three micro
arcs where they'll tell this
self-contained story for like the first
eight episodes that the first half of
the season and then the second half
they'll have like like a second small
story arc when they come back from break
and then finally like their big final
act that the whole season works as a
three-act play so this first half of the
season is probably gonna be her
unlocking her abilities there's a good
reason why she's just as powerful as
Superman but she just doesn't have the
command of her abilities that he does I
can't really explain that in great
detail without getting into spoilers so
I'll just I'll explain that the next
time I do a Supergirl review the other
thing that really grabbed me about the
pilot is the Jimmy Olsen character
they're very clearly setting him up to
be a big deal like when
the few characters that doesn't have any
sinister motives or some side-angle that
he's trying to work just watching out
for Kara on Superman's orders just to
explain the timeline a little bit they
kind of explained it in the trailer but
basically Jimmy Olsen is post Superman
at this point like he's kind of come up
through the ranks made a name for
himself at the Daily Planet Superman
asks him to go help Kara so for those
wondering you know about like where this
exists in the timeline of Batman V
Superman in the movies just consider it
completely separate completely different
characters for those really hoping for
Justice League though I feel like
Supergirl is one step closer to that she
could totally take his place inside like
a full-blown TV Justice League legends
of tomorrow Khanna is that already but
it's closer to Justice Society because
that Vandal Savage just a much bigger
Justice Society villain than he was a
Justice League villain one of the things
I really think they need to work on
though is the fight scenes like it's
really easy to do a fight scene with
Oliver he's a normal human you know he
just does a bunch of krav maga bunch of
spinning shoots people with arrows
pretty simple when we got to Barry they
had to alter his fighting style just
based on his power it's like he's not a
great fighter yet but he's super fast so
he uses his speed in creative ways to
take down bill and so that's really what
I want to see from Supergirl the
temptation when you have like a super
strong character is you just have them
punch through walls that just just do
like a lot of smashy stuff and I don't
think that that's that interesting
because can let me know I feel like they
do have some really interesting
opportunities to use her powers in
creative ways when it comes to taking
down villains or using her powers for
humor the operating mantra is humor
heart spectacle the spectacle part is
pretty easy to do when you have
superpowers the heart is really like
where the supporting characters come in
so I feel like it's gonna take a few
episodes for them to build that team
around Kara before we get a feel for the
moral core of the show her family life
not exactly like Barry's family life she
doesn't have like a Joe or iris West to
anchor herself to they do explore her
relationship with her Kryptonian family
and that's like that's like a really
important part of the pilot but it gets
kind of spoilery so I'll just I'll table
that for now but if you if you do want
to talk about some of the twists with
respect to her family just please use
spoiler tags so really important dates
to remember October 26 that Monday is
the
premiere of the first episode or you
know some of you will just be watching
it again what's probably gonna happen is
is it'll pry run up to the beginning of
December most shows go on break by the
second week in December if not the first
week or before that that's usually when
air on the flash go on break then it'll
come back around the same time air in
the flash come back that's also when
legends of tomorrow starts they haven't
announced when that's gonna premiere but
they're probably gonna do that during
the big DC super panel just a heads up
on that I'm gonna be backstage with like
the arrow and flash people so I'm like
I'm super pumped up about that but they
said that I'm not allowed to record the
screen they will give me some B rolls so
hopefully I will get some footage from
the panel but it's gonna be a little
weird I will be live-tweeting though so
if you want to follow me on Twitter and
Facebook there are links for that in the
description the first panel that I'm
gonna be uploading this week is gonna be
tomorrow they'll either be Doctor Who or
Sherlock so just check my youtube
homepage every once in a while or just
you know just check my Twitter feed so
while you guys wait for the rest of my
Comic Con videos to start posting I'm
gonna add them to my master list you can
click here to see all those videos it's
just like a special Comic Con playlist
and you can click here to learn about
what's going on with the flash and arrow
Comic Con thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys this weekend